[Music]
this morning on the dish a best-selling
cookbook author who knew her calling
very early in life
Julia tertian started thumbing through
cookbooks before she was old enough to
read them and at 13 she launched her
very own little restaurant inside her
parents New York City apartment she
started writing professionally behind
the scenes but when she broke out on her
own she hit it big her first two recipe
books were critically acclaimed
bestsellers she's written for top
newspapers and magazines and she hosts
the Keep Calm and cook on podcast last
year she published her third cookbook
now and again with recipes for both
entertaining and using leftovers along
with personal essays Julia Turchin good
morning welcome to the dish we really
want to dig like we're just holding back
here tell us what we got so we have this
cast iron skillet cornbread that has
cheddar cheese scallions because life is
short and shapes of cheese beet salad
with a poppy seed dressing which is
great because you can make it ahead this
I called celebration chicken and it's
like the ultimate one-pot meal it's
chicken sweet potatoes and dates all
roasted together I love them they're
good in one pan you know no mixing bowl
no nothing this is this delicious
radicchio and roasted squash salad and
this is actually really fun this is the
leftovers from the celebration really
good by the way Oh fantastic yeah this
turns into the most delicious chicken
salad with almonds and chutney and then
this is the applesauce cake with cheese
frosting yeah it's beautiful but it's
also the easiest cake in the world it's
so easy to make I already have a
personal relationship our drink and our
drink is a maple syrup old-fashioned no
cheers Cheers yes now the book which
Anthony mentioned I love this
description a love letter to leftovers
explain that so I am on team leftovers I
love leftovers I've loved them since I
was a really little kid and I think they
elongate a meal you know you get the
best part of the meal from last night
and you get to you know enjoy it again
today right it's also you know it's a
really
Saurus full way to kind of approach the
kitchen and you can make something
completely new so you don't have to just
have the same thing over and over again
you can have a whole new thing and be
really creative and really inventive and
you know just keep your kitchen going we
alluded to this before but basically you
established your your food Empire at the
age of 30 yes yeah Julia's place tell us
all about that it was my restaurant in
my parents apartment the customers were
mostly them and my brother our dog dogs
are always that eaters and it was it was
great it was this time in my life where
I was really finding out what I love to
do and I got so much support for my
family to really do it and to you know
throw myself into the kitchen you know I
never had an easy bake oven an actual
oven right you know and I was empowered
to really explore it which set me up for
everything so why did you then go study
poetry instead of just going right into
food yeah that's a great question I love
language as much as I love cooking and I
knew that I wanted to work on cookbooks
and I wanted to be a writer so I thought
if I could get an education in you know
describing things well and articulating
them and and also just reading things or
learning about things if I could leave
school with this real deep understanding
and love of language it would serve me I
read that you you got a piece of
philosophical advice out of watching an
episode of Dawson's Creek oh really
I didn't read that about that yeah when
I was a teenager the show was on and one
episode where the main character wants
to be a filmmaker and as you know asking
if they should go to film school and
they were given the advice to not
necessarily do that but to kind of learn
about everything so then you have stuff
to make films about and I really took
that to heart because I thought if I
kind of learn about the world I can
express that in my cookbooks you know I
don't just have to study food I can
study people and I'm just everything and
that can come through them I work
do you cook by recipe or mean or you
just kind of put it all together likes a
match my kind of like dirty secret is
that I write recipes for a living I love
writing recipe I never follow
how does that change the way you
approach writing a recipe I approach it
because I want to you know give people
all the tools they they need to be able
to cook intuitively to cook like you
don't have a recipe in front of you to
feel really calm in the kitchen you know
I want people to feel inspired to cook
and then also really again yeah calm
once you're in the kitchen and just and
relaxed and you can do it and it's not a
big deal and everything's gonna turn out
beautifully I'm gonna have you sign the
dish I'm so excited to take if you could
share this new with anyone past or
present who would it be it's such a hard
question but the first person who came
to mine is Lily Tomlin because exactly I
think I would laugh a lot I hope she
would enjoy it and I think the whole
point of cooking is to sit and have a
good time with people and I think she'd
be really she'd be fun yeah chef Juliet
version thank you so much and for more
on Giuliana dish you can head to our
website at CBS this morning calm